okay so we might not see you back you
might not see me back skinny girl mogul
Bethenny Frankel says she has not seen
much of her fellow Real Housewives of
New York lately and it's a conscious
decision
I've been definitely distancing myself
on the show this summer it was a it was
a long year it's it's definitely work
this is just a summer of freedom I'm
doing what I want to do and definitely
making some changes in my personal and
professional life I've just launched a
new watermelon lime margarita with my
cocktail partner so I'm deciding what my
priorities are and kind of how to lay it
out I'm glad that the audience is
enjoying it but I left it behind
I spoke with Bethenny at her home in the
Hamptons where she spent much of the
last few months though she did see the
ladies at the explosive reunion taping
in July was this the hardest reunion
you've ever done by oh by far yeah
something very dramatic happened at the
reunion the question my integrity and
for me if someone questions my business
or my integrity I take it really
seriously and I don't just kind of gloss
over it and so I think that maybe the
fun and late Bethenny that people expect
with the quips and the the comebacks
weren't there the Real Housewives of New
York airs Wednesday nights on Bravo with
the season finale airing August 24th